na liebe zuschauer geht es ihm gut ja
wie schön aber nicht mehr lange freunde
die party ist vorbei goodbye zehn jahre
deutsche aufschwung plötzlich herrscht
untergangsstimmung ja ja nicht
übertrieben die neue steuerschätzung von
olaf scholz sagt wir müssen vielleicht
bald alle hier wie heißt das noch wozu
wie die griechen früher immer gezogen
haben sparen genau sparen eines der
schlimmsten worte die die deutsche
sprache kennt was kommt auf uns zu
die fetten jahre sind vorbei die fetten
jahre sind vorbei
die fetten jahre sind vorbei es hilft
kein prinzip hoffnung mehr
die fetten jahre sind vorbei der jetzige
kassen absturz von olaf scholz zeigt
dass wir einen schritt vor einer echten
wirtschaftskrise stehen nur noch ein
schritt nur noch ein schritt und meine
fetten jahre sind vorbei
gott sei dank gott sei dank lange genug
gedauert
und alle machen mit bei der großen
panikmache ihr bild -zeitung groko
versinkt in 100 milliarden steuerloch da
sag ich doch gute reise und
und der spiegel der spiegel hat als
titelthema rätselhafterweise diese woche
alkoholkranke greifvögel
das scheint ein echtes problem zu sein
von was für löchern und krisen reden wir
hier die deutsche wirtschaft wächst
weiter nur halt langsamer oder mal ganz
simpel ausgedrückt das heißt wir haben
nicht weniger wir haben noch mehr also
wir haben weniger mehr als gedacht aber
es ist immerhin noch mehr so ganz
einfach nochmal für die ganze klasse
freunde dieses jahr haben wir
steuereinnahmen von 324 milliarden euro
in vier jahren sind es dann 360 wenn sie
aufgepasst haben sagen sie das ist mehr
oder noch kindgerechter dein papa hat
ihren ice mit 324 kugeln gekauft
so jetzt willst du fette kleine bratze
aber 400 kugeln also 76 mehr und dann
kauf dir ein geiziger papa nur
zusätzliche 36 jetzt hast du zwar mehr
aber viel weniger mehr dein papa hat
mich überhaupt nicht lieb und deswegen
verprügeln zu ihnen
[Applaus]
mehr
keine panik es ist wirklich unglaublich
die extra kohle sprudelt ein bisschen
langsamer und schon ist diese groko in
der existenzkrise
union und spd wollen offensichtlich nur
noch raus aus dieser zwangsehe wirklich
nur noch raus die union will den sony
komplett streichen auch für die
reichsten zehn prozent die sozen wollen
ihre respekt rente konsequenz stillstand
an allen fronten und dann ist da ja noch
die spannende führungsfrage wer führt
denn eigentlich das land und wie lange
noch freudscher versprecher in 321 für
sie konkret was sie noch die sachen die
sie sich persönlich vornehmen wo es habe
ja gesagt also da ich bis jahresende
jahr noch immer so jedenfalls die
legislaturperiode sagt hab ich ja gesagt
scheiße schöne sportart so schön dass
boiler tja diese woche wurde sie schon
für ämter in brüssel gehandelt
im gegensatz zu annegret kramp
karrenbauer überhaupt kein abend und
leider ganz wenig talent für klartext
mein gott was schwebt die frau sich
einen zusammen hier ganz einfache frage
haben sie den anspruch aufs kanzleramt
und würden sie noch anmelden
es ist so dass die vorsitzende der cdu
natürlich immer auch die verantwortung
hat den prozess wenn es zu einem
regierungswechsel kommt natürlich
beim nächsten mal vor allen dingen so zu
steuern dass die tu in der bestmöglichen
start formation aus steht dass es meine
verantwortung dafür die mich gewählt
werden und diese verantwortung werden
verfahren nun vorbei
wenn sie nicht so laut geklatscht hätten
hätte ich durchgeschlafen meine damen
und herren vielen dank annegret kramp
karrenbauer umso deutlicher hat sie
jetzt gesagt die respekt rente der spd
wird es somit ihr nicht geben es bleibt
also wohl bei der schweinerei dass
rentner die ihr leben lang gearbeitet
aber wegen niedriglohn wenig eingezahlt
haben genauso wenig rente kriegen wir
einer der nie gearbeitet hat nehmer
betroffene hier endlich mal ein
ehrliches wort
die grupo informiert liebe niedriglöhner
kennt den spruch arm aber sexy
das seid ihr im alter nur eine sexy denn
die grundrente die wir seit 2009 in
jedem koalitionsvertrag rätseln die
kommt nicht als ich den quatsch damals
versprochen haben konnten wir nicht
ahnen dass ihr zehn jahre später immer
noch lebt wenn ihr club gewesen wäre
hätte die als junger mann eine alte
millionärin geheiratet
jetzt ist es zu spät nach ya welt uns
bitte trotzdem wir sehen uns an der
angel
so oder so
[Applaus]
klar über bedürftigkeit geht und ja oder
nein
kann man streiten fünf bis acht
milliarden würde die respekt rente
kosten das klingt viel
andererseits verballert die groko allein
zehn milliarden für sinnloses
baukindergeld warum beten wir hier
weiter die schwarze null an
er ist doch irrsinn andere
industrienationen andere länder
investieren gerade massiv in
digitalisierung und forschung wir fallen
in so vielen bereichen gnadenlos zurück
künstliche intelligenz biotechnik das
einzige forschungsfeld wo wir uns noch
richtig reinhängen ist die anti
gravitation forschung fertigten display
und nicht mal da sind wir gut gucken sie
mal hier im katastrophe start und firmen
müssen viel mehr investieren sagen alle
experten zehn jahre aufschwung und
trotzdem marode infrastruktur umfasst
ein kunststück
so ist die marke made in germany
wirklich in gefahr langfristig und
ausgerechnet deutsche premium firmen
schwächeln gerade schwächen akut wegen
eigener fehler
beispiel bayer in leverkusen ja vor
kurzem noch der wertvollste konzern im
dax aber dann hatten sie die durfte idee
monsanto zu kaufen und sie wissen ja was
monsanto herstellt glyphosat summ summ
es bringt uns alle um
offizieller werbeslogan von glyphosat
meine damen und herren
jetzt hat ein gericht in kalifornien sie
haben bestimmt gelesen einem
krebskranken ehepaar zwei milliarden
dollar schadenersatz zugesprochen
milliarden
da muss eine alte frau lange für pillen
drehen sei jemand und über 13.000 klagen
stehen wir in den usa noch aus wir
schauen mal live wo die bayer zentrale
in leverkusen dennis knossalla leitet
dort die nagelneue abteilung für unter
drogeneinfluss getätigte firmenkäufe wie
eng wird das jetzt für bayer
na ja unser konzern hat immer noch einen
börsenwert von 53 milliarden
gut wir haben 56 milliarden für monsanto
bezahlt wenn ich das zusammenrechnen
stehen wir aktuell bei minus 3 sie haben
nicht zufällig drei milliarden euro
dabei ernsthaft haben sie drei
milliarden dabei verdammt ja lacht uns
nur ruhig alle aus im nachhinein hätten
wir vor dem kauf mal googeln sollen wer
oder was monsanto ist klang halt
irgendwie charmant sowie mon cherie
plötzlich stellt sich raus auf die
fertigen gift wir haben hier schon unser
logo geändert
[Musik]
schön geworden aber damit allein
es ist ja nicht getan oder nein wir
bringen auch ein neues medikament raus
gegen chronische fusions schmerzen
aspirin complex für doré pharmakonzerne
die den hals einfach nicht vollkriegen
dasteht
erst denken dann kaufen ich kann es
nicht mehr hören alle hatten nur noch
auf uns herum unser werner baumann ist
der erste dax chef dem die aktionäre das
vertrauen entzogen haben was der sich
anhören muss ich bin hier um mal das
gesicht von einem mann anzugucken wer so
dumm ist die firma zu kaufen
guck mal ein spiegel dann siehst du den
mann der so dumm ist unsere aktie zu
kaufen
[Applaus]
ein bisschen taxi wir tun vielleicht
wenn man bedenkt was diese woche noch
alles rausgekommen ist über eure
hässliche tochter monsanto die führen
listen über ihre kritiker
wissenschaftler journalisten politiker
dazu detaillierte profile wie steht die
person zu glyphosat vielleicht ist sie
zu beeinflussen und wie schaut es im
privatleben aus zuletzt in gruppen
eingeteilt von verbündeter bis hin zu
personen die man überwachen müsse ja
glückwunsch ihr habt euch eine gehst
klitsche und die stasi gekauft werden
eigentlich auch deutsche kritiker
überwacht keine ahnung also klar wenn
wir mal ich weiß nicht eine
fernsehsendung irgendeine sendung
regelmäßig eher schlecht über glyphosat
geredet haben sollte dann will ich nicht
völlig ausschließen dass man da da quasi
aus not werden
aber wir gucken nach vorne herr welke ab
jetzt nur noch fusionen mit firmen die
einen tadellosen ruf wir verhandelt zum
beispiel gerade mit einer
mittelständischen firma aus kolumbien
die nennt sich moment kali drogen
kartell und die haben lustigerweise auch
eine extra abteilung die sich um ihre
kritiker kümmert ich habe da ein gutes
gefühl
hans de schreibt über die heute show ihr
seid die richtigen links [ __ ]
besonders welke die stradivari unter den
arschgeigen bei euch smileys
freudentränen freudentränen
freudentränen freund rennkurs mit herz
vielen dank für ihr freundliches
feedback für ein exklusives geigensolo
von oliver welke
abonnieren sie den kanal